let's bring in Florida Republican and
house Foreign Affairs Committee Member
Mike Waltz Congressman thanks for
joining us and while mayor Adams here in
New York City is warning that this
crisis will destroy the city his own
word he's ripping the current president
for failing to help but he's also
blaming Republicans for the Border
problem listen here
this mess is is Trump trump like
Republicans mess
real immigration reform you know I'm
hearing those who are coming out saying
Eric is Right Eric is right but don't
pick half of what you say I'm right on
pick the other half that Trump
Republicans created this mess and we
need to fix this mess with real
immigration report reform you're a
republican he's blaming Republicans for
creating this mess your response
well that's rich uh and you know New
York City Chicago governor hokel and New
York State welcome to what Texas uh
Arizona the border states uh and even to
a degree Florida has been experiencing
because it's not just over the Border uh
we have uh seaward migration as well
that what we've been experiencing now
for the for the last two years uh he is
right that there's no end in sight
because there's zero effort uh to secure
the Border in fact the bite
Administration is selling the pieces of
the Border they're auctioning off the
pieces that the taxpayers already bought
uh and you know finally because the
mainstream media is not covering it
finally uh the rest of the country is
seeing what these border states have had
to endure and I can tell you in my
community the thing that has people so
upset is when you have veterans that
aren't getting the services that they
deserve when and you have minority
schools and opportunity zones that
aren't getting necessarily what they
deserve schools that are already
overcrowded hospitals that are
overcrowded the bite Administration was
able to get away with this the first
year flying people around in the middle
of the night but now it's reached such
crisis proportion that everybody's
feeling it and I do think the president
is going to continue to see this
political blowback while not naming him
by name he says the White House not
President Biden but the White House has
given no support for the thousands of
Asylum Seekers arriving every month he
blasts Texas governor Greg Abbott as a
Madman for busing the illegal border
crossers to New York and other liberal
cities I mean this is the number of
encounters there in Texas is growing by
the day this is April 2022 I mean that
number we all know by now it's soaring
35 000 migrants have been bused from
Texas to these Sanctuary cities they're
now living what has been the reality on
the ground for these border interstates
for quite some time so does the White
House hear this are they listening
you've got a president that's running
for reelection will there be any change
in their response
and here's here's just the fundamental
flaw in Eric's and Eric Adams criticism
of Republicans if we move to immigration
reform say we do that next week uh when
when we're back in session if you have
an unsecured border you're going to be
right back where you started uh within
months if not if if not years it's just
going the problem is just going to start
all over again it has the solutions have
to be sequential you have to secure the
Border first then you move on to
immigration reform and oh by the way uh
where is Kamala Harris the borders are
in all of this the other solutions that
we've put forward or let's go after the
cartels in a meaningful aggressive way
they're making billions off this human
trafficking and if you want to talk
about root causes let's incentivize
manufacturing to come out of China and
if it can't come to the United States go
into Central America where you're
creating growth creating jobs and not
just throwing American tax dollars at
the problem where corrupt governments
and cartels are just going to skim off
the top anyway and make the problem
worse so we have Solutions Sandra uh but
the bite administration's got to execute
not just throwing tax dollars at the
problem but it's a huge economic you
know struggle for these cities in the
hotels right around these areas where
you have these migrants who are lining
up around the butt that was Roosevelt
Hotel we keep showing the video of it
still looks like that right now for the
many of us who go by there every day it
is a problem that is clearly only
getting worse in this city we'll see
where it goes next Congressman
appreciate you joining us thank you hey
everyone I'm Emily compagno catch me and
my co-host Harris Faulkner and Kaylee
mcineny on outnumbered every weekday at
12 p.m Eastern or sets your DVR also
don't forget to subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube page for daily highlights